good afternoon councillors
and uh welcome along to our october
meeting um
[Music]
[Music]
um
various uh earlier meetings
um confirmation of the minutes of the
ordinary meeting of council
held on tuesday 8th september
um
is there any operation required to their
report
it's not a good promotion all those in
favor please stand up
there is one item that has been notified
himself
so one item to be transacted in
committee
and relates to wastewater discharges
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and again we have some information to be
received
um and it relates to the royal special
fund
and uh direction from the royal special
fund
committee um
fund to offset debt
for rural bridge
and maintenance and construction going
forward and
with some required movement they've been
received
quite a lot of debate as to as to what
it should be useful or
not useful and and the decision of
council
some time ago was to put it aside and
just let it
get a momentum in terms of interest
but this looks like a pretty worthwhile
investment from from my perspective so
we'll be interested to see if any other
counselors have any view but
um
[Music]
it's obviously i uh
a fund that's held in very high guard
um by the rural community and it will be
interesting to see
in light particularly of the prevailing
interest rate environment
those
community
[Music]
which is the ncta financial assistance
rate and the fact that it has moved from
55
to 59 which is fantastic
and a program of power that
extra funding might be often used
[Music]
especially around the rural focus
um
okay so the item is now open uh for
discussion
and or recommendation
um your worship i was just wondering how
much um
lifting the rural graveling by a hundred
thousand does that actually bring us up
to
what the engineers expect to be in
maintenance
it gets us about where we need be
[Music]
thank you any other question though
uh
installations how do you know if the
installation is going to be permanent
[Music]
but
this
so the idea is to allocate some some
money
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
if the trial costs are less than 100
can those healthcare monies be
directed
okay
so i think the idea
feel comfortable they've gone
i need to um the report and then agree
to the
investment for the future to be reviewed
after the first
sort of involvement in
the streets
yeah i was just uh three worship i was
just going to indicate with regarding
that increase with a meddling budget
that obviously the survey that's carried
out will be carried out again
to see what percentage of the road users
have been satisfied with
what's been applied when we look it down
as a provider that extra funding
that would be one of the additions
yeah so be returned back to council so
they see that improvement
or non-improvement depending on the
situation
that i'd be happy to see
[Music]
i have another question
through your worship it's pleasing to
see the
british replacement weight
requirements a heavy weight requirement
because it's a
impediment to farmers and and i think to
rural transports
i'm wondering how many there are in the
district and
how quickly that the funding to upgrade
them
[Music]
[Music]
is
is
to upgrade all the bridges in southern
district which
quite a few little dollars but literally
nothing about
the district would come for a
maintenance point known to
people in national circles and they have
a copy of that
british report and it should be a
they have any influence on budget
consumers going forward
then any funding that's coming into the
city
so council
are you going to have some sort of
protective project budget
going forward once you know you've done
your trials because
if you're only allowing 60 grand it
might be a lot higher
and we could end up in a year's time
saying
that you want a hundred thousand dollars
to process this
the streets of life program
you know you've got a nearly a million
dollars to spend on this program but you
haven't got any money
on the so-called permanent structure
as such all right temporary structure
some signs will stay some may i just i'm
just a little bit concerned that you're
going to come back to me and say
oh i need another 100 000 because
streets of life programs have been a
success
and we want to implement this but
there's no money in the budget for it
but i need money for it
if you understand what i'm talking about
so where do you think you might get that
budget money from
uh um
um
okay so you're going to say then that
you'll probably defer some of the
long-term maintenance project projects
that you have already on your box
at the moment to do
budget or increase in the budget so that
that will need for councils
at that point in time whether that's an
appropriate
use of funding or not but
yeah engaging with the community is a
fantastic thing
and it has to happen but it does
throw up issues that councils are going
to have to grasp
as time goes on and we're going to get
more and more
some serious things
i still think it was a misleading
project was put to us um
there's a package for the streets live
and i was going to cover all the costs
and now we've got some bills foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
okay um
[Music]
grant so we've got two grants for us
okay again
right um we'll move on into automate
which is
this project was in danger of having
paralysis
by our analysis and analysis in terms of
which
[Music]
mr matt russell who has made himself
available
to work three days a week on
the investigation of whether the option
is for
services and three waters given the
national direction that's coming at us
um in forceful way um
i think the first phase here is uh you
see in paragraph 11 with the middle of
the week
and just talks about the priorities that
mr russell will be charged with
so in relation to the condition of
assets which
and authority
compliance performance issues and key
projects and priorities so
from just a google district perspective
it would be quite useful to see
what other councils are faced with and
place ourselves
context i think each council believes
it's
uh a song full of alligators
[Music]
and things like asset position where
um and then compliance and performance
we do get reports uh from the regional
council
and useful just to line all that up
so because ultimately i think people
want to know if they're
[Music]
[Music]
keep appraised
as a false timeline because
its position in regards to participating
further than
the stimulus funding package and
the investigation required year off
from central government so we've only
got as we stand
seven months
will have more of a binding
[Music]
um
[Music]
that whatever a
structure might look like going forward
is likely to be
at least the size of what we talked
about here today
it may well be back but at least this
gives us a really good sense of
what's possible what the challenges are
and
will be fit
okay
and then moving on from the election
um probably one to two percent of the
population in the new zealand and uh
listen to are we going to actually get a
voice
at the table or um
where is it going to be implemented by
government and put down upon us
but i think you can be sure
there is quite a strong view across the
south island
rather than the whole
who knows what the future's like but
i think whatever the shape of government
going for this
is going to change this is
the view of the current administration
regarding our water structure under the
ground and give us a database of
what needs to be maintained and
reviewed so i'll let somebody else
answer that but my understanding is acid
evaporation is a big
part of muscle's problem so that will
obviously
be able to once you've done that
evaluation
is
whereas older communities
[Music]
so i don't matt russell was not there
too
he wouldn't have enough time during the
asset condition
for each council what he will be doing
is looking at okay what is the data each
council has
does that mean that we will be upgrading
our database on
because just listening to equip three
waters today
um they said it was a priority to
actually
have that database of the infrastructure
we are continuously striving to obtain
the
condition of the data and the edge of
the data currently we have challenges of
the integrity of the data we have
we are continuously revalidating it i
think i have put a special
task force on to to make sure we
generate as accurate data as we as a
building new one
and the backlog of whatever asset data
we don't have
we have to keep continuously updating
you
said that um worship if you reflect on
last month's account you allocated
a size for portrait stimulus funding for
cctv
which is directly related to finding
another questions
[Music]
how much money needs to be set aside for
this
investigative project um so initially
there was just uh
a thought of a million dollars across
the two regions with cut
mustard in
members
[Music]
affairs so
this has resulted in a slight increase
in the council's property commission for
that study
which in turn has a slightly effect
on the amount approved
for the seamless package so the
intensity system reduced
by uh 49 000 the
allocation to the living street based
renewal and um
it's the trunk it's
um
the existing contract of interim renewal
triggered after the flooding we have
used the same value
to allocate the money for extending the
renewal of that existing weekend
sewer trunk so we hope it will be within
the budget
cctv
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
exactly how much is
[Music]
[Music]
is
um up the importance of
understanding um the condition of their
assets
across the town uh versus investing in
one single asset
so that's sort of what happens
[Music]
um
[Music]
there will be a requirement for further
investment
in the future so it's just
so both projects
[Music]
we want to just save any money that we
possibly
um
a comment that that's a bit what can uh
like what council
uh bulger has stated that as councillors
we need to place our trust in
the uh water managers to be advising us
where where this
costs come from and as long as we're not
robbing peter to pay paul a situation
like that that
it turns around we've got to find money
somewhere else along the line
um
[Music]
they're indicating to us that the larger
project is the most appropriate one to
absorb
and we have to endorse that
[Music]
is that the cctv footage
of the district is vitally important
because it's going to guarantee how much
money that we actually need to spend
why their infrastructure has actually
failed how much has failed how many
kilometers we need to be placed
and it may indicate in the future
to the to the whatever the identity
might be how much money is allocated to
the goal district that includes terry
and white gecko
and i i'm hoping it's going to be a lot
but just remember that we're only a
small small council
and the big players in the in the world
always swallow up with other ones all
the time so
we've got to probably fight tooth and
now for everything we can get
and as i say it's vitally important that
we have the right
numbers
you need to know what your systems are
like you can't budget or prepare
any sort of plan if you don't know
what's under the ground you're dealing
with so you've
got to put your money into cctv it's
going to
even increase that budget if you had to
know what you're dealing with
then you can work you know what's there
you can work out a budget
plan don't know what to see it's really
hard to play
don't play
[Music]
okay um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
duties as general management regulatory
and community services
and so this is a council
delegation that you must prove specific
to the officer
and so taking
[Music]
um
all right
[Music]
just clarification so when it comes to
[Music]
um
program to engage with both youth
who are disengaged and adults who have
been
um
delivery
trust will
navigator so that's a person that's very
hands-on
in terms of working with the individuals
and the coordinator will be employed by
the council
and the coordinator will be uh
probably us slightly out but connected
quite strongly to the
classical care but also very strongly
connected to the potential employers
and actual employers as
well as being connected to the various
agencies that can help those people
along the way so so hopefully this is
going to be
pretty successful and if it is
successful then
there is a very strong possibility to
carry on into the future
it's really just a it's
[Music]
the part of the key navigator i think is
pretty much being identified um
quite soon the
to be received
yes